from powerful speeches it is very
important be a good human two shocking
wins
[Applause]
e.t is taking a look at the best moments
of the 2020 emmy awards
or should we say the pandemies welcome
to the pandemies
you know what they say you can't have a
virus without a host
host jimmy kimmel kicked off the big
night and no
that's not a real audience something
kimmel realized when he was seeing
double
if i'm down there how am i
up here that would mean that no one is
in the audience that would mean that
i'm up here all alone
yep the ceremony looked a lot like 2020
hazmat suits hand sanitizer stations
covet tests oh wow that's deep you're in
there okay
and all the nominees joined in virtually
i feel like i'm in a best buy
this is wonderful jennifer aniston was
there to help jimmy announce the first
winner of the big night
the pair took extra precaution to
sanitize the envelope by setting it on
fire after dousing it in lysol spray
once all the germs have been burned off
okay here we go
perfect a
perfect metaphor for the moment in time
got it right shit's creek walked away
with a record-breaking nine total awards
and the emmy goes to
creek shit's creek shit's free shit's
creep
annie murphy won her first trophy for
outstanding supporting actress in a
comedy series
and dan levy took home his first acting
emmy for supporting actors
it still feels very strange um
but what an absolutely unbelievable way
to end our series i don't think you
could ever ask for a better
conclusion to a story than than tonight
so
we are absolutely thrilled schitt's
creek may have
ended but we have a feeling that this
isn't going to be the last time we see
the cast together
here's what they told e.t does this mean
that there will be
some kind of return or maybe a movie i
would absolutely love to continue
telling these stories it's been the
greatest
pleasure and the greatest gift it was a
powerful night of speeches
stars like mark ruffalo and regina king
encouraged viewers to vote as they
accepted their award for lead actor
and actress in a limited series vote for
love
and compassion and kindness have a
voting plan
go to ballypedia.com vote up the ballot
please
zendaya made history as the youngest
emmy winner for lead actress for her
role
in euphoria the 24 year old was stunned
beyond belief while accepting her first
emmy win this is um this is pretty crazy
i don't really cry i'm incredibly
grateful and
and honored i mean just to have my
family here and that love and that
support in this room
meant so much to me to be able to share
this moment with all of them and
um yeah i'm just i'm just you know happy
and grateful
and just a lot of emotions something
that gave us
all the feels the unexpected friends
reunion with jennifer aniston
courtney cox and lisa kudrow we live
together
you do
uh yeah we've been roommates since 1994
jimmy what i thought that was i had no
idea
is it is this live tv unbelievable
and what a mood the cast of little fires
everywhere
celebrated the new year early because
well duh
2020. but it's not even midnight